Alhamdulillah.
[Silence]
Continuing with the remaining verses of
Surah. Surah Mud is chapter number 74
in the order of the mus that we have.
Chapter number 74.
were written on in the time of
and even before that in the time of Abu
Bakr and Omar. This is the order that
the chapters were written in and this is
something that they learned from the
prophet sallall.aii wasallam. Chapter
number 74
verses number 38-
48. Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala says
every soul by what it has earned of sin
is hostage is captive by that sin by
said sin. Every soul, believer and
non-believer, every soul
is held captive, held hostage
by what it has earned and by its own
sin. Allah says
except for the people of the right
meaning the people of paradise.
This is exactly what the prophet
sallall.aii
says in the narration of Annis which
many of us are familiar with in which he
says
and narrates that the prophet
sallall.aii alaihi wasallam said every
child of Adam is a sinner
and
the good amongst the sinners are the
ones who are constantly in repentance
that is really the difference it really
boils down to that doesn't it between
the believer and the disbeliever
because a person's repentance to Allah
can only be accepted on The foundation
of belief in Allah in the last day,
belief inahillahillham.
Many people repent but this is an act of
worship and every act of worship has to
be has to be chiseled on the key of
as the companions have said that
The key to paradise is
so here Allah says
every soul by what it has earned of sin
is captive is captive in punishment is
guilty by their own sin except for the
people of the Right. Ib Kir told us and
we've said this before that they are
referred to as the people of the right
for three reasons. Do we remember those
three reasons?
Who can remember with me recall why we
call them the people of the right in the
Quran? The people of paradise. They are
the people of the right. Why are they
the people of the right?
Where did they get this name from?
because they will be given their books
in their right hand. That's number one.
Number two,
[Arabic recitation]
those souls, I hope that we were amongst
them. You and I were on the right of
Adam.
And the third reason
they will be again
because they will be on the rights of
the throne of Allah on the day of
judgment. Mashallah. Somebody is
listening. This makes me so happy.
Alhamdulillah. Mashallah.
So this is why they are called. Allah
then describes their state of being. He
says,
He said the people of the right they
will be in Janet
in Janette in gardens
in gardens.
Now these janet, this word janet is
plural and it is plural for the word
jenna
and a principle of the Arabic language.
When the gimm and the noon combine in a
word, that word will always carry the
meaning of concealment.
One
settle.
[Silence]
And so wherever we find in the Arabic
language that the gimm and non combine
this articulates the meaning of
concealment.
This is why we call the jin jin. Why are
they called the jin? The jin kind.
They are called jin because they are
concealed. We cannot see them.
Or for instance, el janine. Janine is a
fetus. It is concealed. Is a human being
that's concealed and we don't know what
its gender is or its state of being
until it's born traditionally.
Or al jenna which is a garden. But a
Jenna is not just any garden. Remember,
it carries the meaning of concealment.
A Jenna in the Arabic language is a
garden that is so lush
and it is so thick
that its canopy conceals those who are
in it. Meaning that it's such a thick
and lush garden that if you were a
bird's eyee view, you would not be able
to see who is in it. It would conceal
the people inside of it. This is why
it's called a Jenna.
And these people, the people of the
right, they're not just in one jenna.
They are in Jenna.
They are in a variety
of gardens, lush, rich gardens as Allah
describes
these men and these women whom Allah has
blessed with being the people of the
right. They are in these lush gardens
where they will enjoy themselves and
they will also question
what happened to those of their past.
Allah says
they will be in these paradise. They
will be in these lush gardens
asking about the criminals. Where did
they go? Where did they end up? Those
people that we advised, those people who
antagonized us, those people who
hindered us constantly from the path of
Allah, those men who met us on the
battlefield trying to cut with their
swords and their tongues,
where did they end up? Where are they?
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala says,
They will be asking the people of the
hellfire, what has placed you? What what
is it that ended you up in this
damnation and in this hell? And here for
the second time in the same chapter, we
have the word.
And if you notice something
about the Quran that the scholars have
mentioned,
each chapter,
the longer chapters this, the first
three quarters of the Quran,
they have a individualized and unique
diction.
What does that mean? That means that
each chapter in its opening verses will
use particular words and the rest of the
chapter will bring up those words again
or revolve around the meanings of those
unique words.
And this is one of the incredible
miracles and shows the precision of the
Quran. Each chapter is unique. It's it's
very clearly distinct from its
counterpart chapters yet it all has the
same tone and the same author which is
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala. So here for
the second time we have the word again
which we said that
is what what does mean? Does anybody
remember?
Let's make it a little bit interactive.
What is the meaning of?
Yes.
[Arabic recitation]
Correct. And it's also what? It's also
said three things. The scholars mention
it's one of the levels of hell.
One of the doors, one of the gates of
hell, one of the gates of the hellfire.
seven gates. Allah says he tells us is
one of the names of those seven gates.
And the third,
it's a general term used to refer to all
of the hellfire
in general. Right? So we say meaning
hell, sar more specifically a gate of
hell, more specifically a level of hell.
These three meanings are what the
companions and have mentioned with
regards to the word.
To finish up, we've only got a couple
more minutes left. These people in
paradise, they will be asking about the
people of the hellfire. Now, I want you
to imagine this with me. How large is
paradise? Allah describes paradise as
that an individual level of paradise
could be as wide and as vast as the
heavens and the earth. The prophet
sallall.aii alaihi wasallam said that
each person will look to the next level
of paradise and the next level right
above him the nearest level of paradise
will look a distant star in the
sky. This is how incredibly vast
paradise is. And we know that paradise
has at least how many levels? Anyone
know? Yes.
[Arabic recitation]
That those are the gates of paradise.
There are eight gates of paradise. But
how many levels of paradise?
[Arabic recitation]
Much much much more than seven.
Tell us.
Just like
I mean you're going to be asked to
then you got to go up based on how
[Arabic recitation]
narration of Abdullahb
in which the prophet tells us that the
person of the Quran will be said it will
be said to him recite and rise with
every verse that you read for your final
position will be at the final verse that
you had learned from the dunya. Correct?
in his book
said.
He said
that the scholars have mentioned this
narration as an evidence that the levels
of paradise are at least as numerous as
the verses of the Quran. Subhan Allah.
This is of the great mercy of Allah. And
the higher you go, the closer you become
to the throne of Allah. And the higher
you go in paradise, the closer you are
to the level which our prophet
sallall.aii wasallam is to reside in.
So these levels of paradise if you can
imagine how vast then you imagine the
hellfire. The prophet sallall.aii
wasallam tells us that some people will
continue to fall in hell for 70 years
not reaching its bottom. So here's the
question. How are these people of
paradise sitting in paradise speaking to
the people of hell with these distances
between them? We see for instance in
surah
that there is a discussion between the
people of paradise and the people of
hell that the people of hell will call
out and say give us something from what
Allah has given you and they will
respond to them and have a dialogue.
Well, how is this possible if they are
so far apart?
Anyone know the answer to that question?
Okay.
Allah mentions that
that there will be a wall that will be
driven between the people of hell and
the people of paradise. Correct? But
this is in the beginning stages before
each enters into his final place of
paradise. In this verse, Allah clearly
says
that they will be in their places in
paradise, but then they will be
simultaneously able to discuss and have
a discussion,
a a dialogue and a conversation with the
people of the hellfire that are in the
depths of hell and in the heights of
paradise.
Paradise is a very unique place which we
will answer this question tomorrow.
[Silence]
[Arabic recitation]